hi everyone
this is professor m das science and
today i want to discuss the density
operator for mixed states
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics
for quantum state for which we have full
information which we call pure states
we know that the density operator
provides an alternative formulation
to that of state vectors today i want to
generalize these ideas to mixed states
which are states that we use to describe
situations where we only have
partial information the density operator
will make our life much easier
when we have to deal with mixed states
which are for example important
when we study quantum statistical
mechanics so today's topic is extremely
important and extremely useful
let's go let's start with a reminder on
the distinction between
pure and mixed states and as always
check out the videos in the description
for further details
a pure state is one for which we have
full information
we describe it with a cat psi which
encodes all we can know about the state
for example we can predict its time
evolution by solving the joining
equation
it is important to understand that in
quantum mechanics full knowledge of
state has a probabilistic dimension
which appears when we measure physical
properties to see that imagine we have
an observable a
and the eigenvalue equation the
eigenstates u n
provide the basis of state space so we
can always expand psi in this basis
where as usual the expansion
coefficients are given by the bracket
use psi
postulate 4 of quantum mechanics says
that when we measure a
then the only possible outcome is one of
the eigenvalues lambda n
with probability equal to the absolute
value of c n squared
this probability here is fundamental in
quantum mechanics
and even when we know everything there
is to know about the state we can only
predict the probability of a given
measurement outcome
let's now compare this to a mixed state
it is a state for which we only have
incomplete information which is
something that can happen in the quantum
or the classical worlds
to be concrete our system could be in
state psi 1
or in state psi 2 or in general in state
psi k
each of this state is a pure state but
crucially
in a mixed state we don't know which one
is the one for our system
what we know is that the likelihood of
state psi 1 is p1
the probability that it is in state psi
2 is p2
and so on our system is in some state
so for this to make sense the sum over
all these probabilities
must equal one so the p
probabilities encode the lack of
knowledge about which state our system
is in
and they're independent of quantum
mechanics the same can happen in
classical systems
a prominent example of this is when the
system is microscopic
with the number of particles of the
order of avogadro's number
with so many particles we cannot fully
characterize the system
be classically or quantum mechanically
what we do instead is to use probability
in the context of
statistical mechanics for example a
system at thermodynamic equilibrium at
temperature t
has a probability of having energy e
proportional to e to the minus e over
kbt
where remember kb is boltzmann's
constant
what we'll see today is that the density
operator is an extremely useful tool to
describe
mixed states
let's first have a quick refresher about
the density operator for pure states
and you can find more details in the
corresponding video linked in the
description
for a pure state psi k we define the
density operator rho k
as the outer product of psi k with
itself
for pure states the density operator
provides a formalism that is equivalent
to that of state vectors
just to give you an example we can
calculate the expectation value of an
operator
a as the trace of the density operator
times the a operator
this is equivalent to the usual
expectation value in terms of state
vectors
as another example we can also look at
measurements consider the eigenvalue
equation for operator a
and also define the projector pn onto
the subspace u n associated with
eigenvalue lambda n
then the probability of measuring lambda
n is given by the trace over the density
operator
multiplied by the projection operator pn
the equivalent expression in terms of
state vectors
is given by this now this expression
isn't the most common for p lambda n so
if you need a refresher you can check
out the videos on measurements
so for pure states we can work either in
terms of state vectors
or in terms of the density operator it
is usually more convenient to work in
terms of state vectors
and this is why most of you will have
encountered quantum mechanics using
state vectors
however it turns out that for mixed
states it is more convenient to do
quantum mechanics using the density
operator
and today we'll see how expressions such
as these generalize to mixed states
the key reason why the density operator
is more useful for mixed states is
because in all these formulas the
density operator appeared in a linear
manner
where the state vector can appear in a
quadratic manner for example the
expression for the expectation value
here
has the density operator only once but
the corresponding expression has a state
vector twice
let's now move to a mixed state in which
the state psi
k appears with probability pk
such that the sum over all pk equals one
so here is the key question today how
can we make calculations in quantum
mechanics
when we have a statistical mixture each
individual psi k
is a pure state and for those we can
apply the usual rules of quantum
mechanics
we can then calculate the result for the
statistical mixture
by averaging the results for the
individual states and weighing each
state by how likely it is to be there
which is the probability encoded by the
pk
although this strategy would in
principle work we'll see that the math
is typically rather tedious
to make the discussion more concrete
let's imagine that we have some
observable a
with the dissociated eigenvalue equation
and we also have a particular pure state
psi k
let's now ask the question what is the
probability of measuring lambda n
in this state i label this probability
with the sub-index k
here to clarify that it corresponds to
psi k
we've just discussed that this
probability can be written as the trace
of the product rho k with pn
where row k is the density operator for
the pure state psi k
and pn is the projection operator onto
the eigenstate associated with the
eigenvalue lambda n that we measure
i'm assuming throughout that the
eigenvalues are non-degenerate for
simplicity
but extending this to the general
eigenvalue is actually straightforward
so now that we have the probability of
measuring lambda
n in each pure state psi k then the
total probability of measuring lambda n
in the statistical mixture is equal to
the sum
over the likelihood that each state is
there multiplied by the probability that
we measure lambda n
in that state using this expression we
just derived up here
we can rewrite it like this
so this is it this here is an example of
how we calculate something like the
probability of a measurement outcome
when we have a mixed state
to make progress we need to remember the
result that the trace is a linear
operation
so that the trace of a scalar a times
the matrix m
is equal to the scalar a multiplying the
trace of the matrix m
using this property we can move the sum
of a p k
inside the trace because the pk are
simply scalars
and we then get that the overall
probability of getting lambda n in the
mixed
state can be rewritten like this
now we come to the key step note that if
we call this object here
row then we end up with trace over rho
pn this expression now has the same form
as the expression we got for the
probability outcome of a measurement
in a pure state up here this motivates
us to define
the density operator for mixed states
which we call
rho as the sum over k of pk
times the density operator for each
individual pure state rho k
now let me highlight this definition
this is the starting point for
all our work with mixed states it is
telling us that the density operator for
a mixed state is simply
the average of the density operators of
each individual pure state making up the
statistical mixture
with this choice we at least get the
same expression for the probability of a
given measurement outcome between pure
mixed states
what we'll see in the rest of the video
is that this definition also means that
all other relevant equations take the
same form for the density operator for
pure
and for mixed states but before we go
into this
the very first thing we can already say
is that the density operator is
hermitian
which follows trivially from the fact
that each individual row k
is hermitian
this expression for the density operator
rho of a mixed state
is linear in the density operator for
the individual pure states row k
as we discussed earlier all the relevant
quantities in quantum mechanics
written in terms of the density operator
for pure states are linear
and this means that they will generalize
to the case of mixed states in a very
simple manner
to see this let's start with
normalization for pure state we have
this
using an analogous formula for a mixed
state we can now insert the definition
of rho
as the trace is linear we can take this
out and we get this
this is now the trace of the density
operator of a pure state
so it is 1 and we end up with this
finally for statistical mixture the sum
over all probabilities is equal to 1.
this means that the trace of the density
operator in a mixed state
is also equal to one and this captures
the normalization of both the pure
states making up the mixture
here and the normalization of the
physical mixture here
let's now look at expectation values of
operators
for a pure state we have this
now to see how this generalizes to a
mixed state the first thing we'll do is
to rewrite the operator a
in a somewhat unusual form that will
nonetheless prove very convenient
to do that let's write the eigenvalue
equation for a
and also the operator pn that projects
onto the eigenstate u n
we can then rewrite the operator a in
this somewhat unusual form
where again i'm using non-degenerate
eigenvalues for simplicity
so we first need to convince ourselves
that this is indeed a valid expression
for a
to see that all we have to do is to show
that both sides give the same result
when acting on an arbitrary state
so let's start with the left hand side
which gives a acting on psi
we can expand psi in the u basis
we can then move the operator inside the
sum
and this is just the eigenvalue equation
for a
so we get sum over m cm lambda m um
now let's repeat the exercise using the
right hand side which gives this
acting on psi we can expand the
projection operator
and also psi in the u basis we can then
rearrange the expression to get this
the basis is orthonormal so this is
delta n m
and the double sum reduces to this
single sum over m
comparing this expression with this
expression
we confirm that they are equal so that
we can indeed write an operator a
in this form up here so let's make some
room by erasing this proof we're now
ready to look at the expectation value
of
a in the mixed state we know from the
videos on expectation values
that one of the many expressions for an
expectation value is simply
given by the sum of the eigenvalues
weighted by the probability of obtaining
each eigenvalue
in a statistical mixture of states we
have already discussed earlier
that we can write this probability as
the trace of the density operator like
this
getting this new expression
using the linearity of the trace we can
move this scalar inside
and we get this
looking up here this is just the
operator a
and overall this means that we can write
the expectation value of a as the trace
over the density operator
multiplied by a we therefore see
again the expression for an expectation
value generalizes to the mixed state by
simply replacing the density operator
row k
of a pure state up here by the density
operator rho
for the mixed state here
okay so now we come to time evolution
for a pure state
we have this
mixed state remember we don't know what
precise state we're in
we only know the statistical
distribution of states however
we're going to assume that the
hamiltonian of the system is known
which is something that usually happens
this means that each state making up our
statistical mixture
follows this equation for pure states
using this we can calculate the time
derivative of the density operator for
the mixed state
using the definition of rho we get this
we can then move the derivative here to
get this
this is now the time evolution of the
density operator for a pure state
and we can insert this expression into
this
to get this
we can next move this scalar in here
and we get this
this here is the density operator for
the mixed state
so overall we get this time evolution
for rho
so again the expression for the time
evolution generalizes to the mixed state
by simply replacing the density operator
row k
for a pure state up here and here we
launch the operator row for the mixed
state here
and here but the form of the equation
stays the same
what we've seen so far is that the
density operator is very convenient
because all we have to do to move
between pure and mixed states is to
change from this expression for pure
states
to this expression for mixed states and
doing that
all formulas relating to normalization
expectation values measurement or time
evolution of the system
then take the same form although the
fact that all equations take the same
form is clearly very convenient
it can actually sometimes be a little
problematic we could find ourselves with
a density operator
to which we can do anything we want with
the relevant equations of quantum
mechanics
but because they are the same between
pure and mixed states we may actually
not know whether the row that we have
corresponds to a pure
or to a mixed state what we then need is
a way to tell the two types of density
operator apart
to see how let's start with a pure state
psi k
whose density operator is this
we know from the video on the density
operator for pure states that this row
is simply a projection operator
and as such it is even potent which
means that row k
squared equals row k once we have this
result
another one follows immediately consider
the trace of row k squared
it is equal to the trace of row k
because row k is either impotent
and due to normalization this gives one
now here is the key point we'll see in a
moment that these two relations that
appear very fundamental
in fact do not hold for mixed states
as you can now guess this will then give
us a way to distinguish the density
operators
of pure mixed states
let's quickly write down again what we
just found about the density operator
for pure states
now what about a mixed state remember
that the density operator is this
which we can also spell out like this
let's first check if rho is still a
projector by calculating rho squared
expanding row we get the sum over k
and the sum over l
we can rearrange this expression to get
this where i am also expanding the row k
and rho l in terms of outer products
now at this point and for simplicity
we'll assume that the different states
in the statistical mixture are
orthogonal
so we get delta kl here this means that
the double sum reduces to a single sum
of a k
and finally we recover row k from the
outer product
to get this
so what do we have we see that here
there is a pk squared rather than a pk
so that this final expression
is not equal to rho this means that the
density operator is not idempotent in
the mixed case
so it isn't the projection operator
we can also calculate the trace of rho
squared
we can use this expression here for rho
squared
to write this as equal to the trace of
the sum of a k
of pk squared row k
as the trace is a linear operation and
the pk are scalars
we can take this out and we rewrite the
expression to get this
this is the normalization condition for
a pure state
and we therefore get the sum of a k of
pk squared
now for a mixed state the sum over all
pk equals one
as a mixed state is by definition a
state in which at least
two different pk are non-zero because if
we only had
one non-zero pk then that would be a
pure state
then this means we can write this
condition
on the value of any pk as long as our
list 2pk are non-zero
then any other pk may be zero so here we
have that pk
is in general larger than or equal to
zero
but to have a mixed state at least 2pk
must be non-zero
and as the sum over all pk equals 1 then
no individual pk
can be equal to 1. so here we have a
strict inequality
this implies that for mixed states pk
squared is smaller than pk
because pk is strictly smaller than 1.
as the sum over all pk equals 1 then the
sum here
over all pk squared must be strictly
smaller than 1.
so summarizing for a mixed state the
density operator is not a projection
operator
and the trace of rho squared is strictly
smaller than one
this is it if we have a density operator
all we have to do is to calculate either
its square
or the trace of its square if the
operator is idempotent
as shown up here it is a pure state and
if it isn't as shown down here
it is a mixed state alternatively if
this trace up here
is equal to 1 then we have a pure state
and if it is smaller than one as down
here we have a mixed state
we can use either condition to figure
out what sort of state we have
to summarize for a pure state we have
this density operator
and for mixed state this one it then
follows that the usual expressions of
quantum mechanics
for example these ones here take the
same form between pure states
and mixed states the one
difference between these operators is
that in the pure case the density
operator is a projection operator
which leads to the trace of the square
being equal to 1
whereas in the mixed state it is in the
projection operator
and the rays of the square is strictly
smaller than 1.
the density operator is a very
convenient way of describing mixed
states
the relevant equations of quantum
mechanics take the same form between
pure and mixed states all we have to do
to go from one to the other
is to use the relevant definition of the
density operator although for pure
states the density operator formalism is
rarely used and we typically prefer the
state vector formalism for mixed states
you'll pretty much always find yourself
using the density operator formalism
as always if you liked the video please
subscribe